comment tu vas fabien ça va ça va
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que qu'avant
d'être enfin puma depuis ma sortie su
j'ai l'impression de réapprendre tout en
fait ouais c'est savons que c'est c'est
une renaissance et je réalise ou pas
vous pas complètement encore ça fait
quoi rêver toujours ça fait deux jours
et ouais c'est ça ça fait deux jours que
j'ai mis le pied dehors dansant sans
murs de prison sans barbelés ça fait ça
fait bizarre quoi ça fait bizarre mais
mais en bien bien sûr et voilà c'est
quelque chose que j'essaie de mètres
derrière moi mais c'est encore quand
même un peu un peu présent alors tu qui
préparait bien entendu à sortir on avait
entendu deux fois l'accès serait dans
les prochains jours mais tient pas cru
jusqu'au dernier moment si c'est une
fois que tu es vraiment jusqu'au dernier
moment j'ai pas que je ne pensais pas
d'une que serait transféré de turquie en
france et de 2
ma sortie là il ya deux jours moi je
l'attendais pour le 6 mars 2022 4 est
donc là
ils m'ont annoncé pardon vendredi
dernier vendredi il y à il ya dix jours
et dix jours que j'allais sortir
marre de ce mardi ce mardi comment on
vit ça quand on dit tu vas sortir tue
tête d'une petite appréhension tu dis je
sois là j'ai peur que ça se fasse pas ou
bien tu entends des francos des français
je n'ai pu sur quelques que deux que
deux côtés mais
est ce qu'il y avait eu n'appréhende pas
une appréhension de sortir une envie de
certains sur noël de revoir mais ne
savent pas que ce soit encore reculé
côté français non j'ai pas eu de rejet
pour celle qui était sûr et situations
alors pour toi en béton donc très
pouvait passer c'est vrai qu'elle est
formidable
pour toi tout a commencé en 2017 quand
tu te rends à istanbul pour faire des
implants capillaires capillaire c'est
sous les halles a
annoncé me maquillais
alors pendant ce séjour tu va commander
te faire livrer à ton d'hôtel du gbl
cette substance est interdite en turquie
depuis seulement quelques semaines et là
c'est le début d'un calvaire incroyable
tu sais même pas que cette substance est
interdite en fait eu de toi tu es dans
ta tête tu commandes jeu en fait j'ai
commandé depuis j'étais en israël et je
les commande et sur un site internet qui
est tout à fait face à un site comme
comme i'm on ne pas dire de ne pas dire
que maintenant n'importe nawak importe
quel site web avec ma carte de crédit
alors que mon adresse de domiciliation
avec que livraison à mon hôtel et en
fait quand j'ai reçu j'ai ouvert le
paquet devant la réceptionniste et puis
on va dire vous êtes je me suis
retournée et -10 vous êtes content il
reste
ça a été l'année de son arrestation elle
se déroule comme on oct et cesse ça se
passe où donc tout le paquet autorité
directe j'ouvre le paquet ouais je me
retourne pour aller glaner dans ma
chambre est assurée quand je me retourne
dans la police et la m e mail me let me
met les menottes et là tu te rends
compte de ce qui se passe tu dis tu te
dis quoi tu essaies sur leur ligne que
leur dit quoi tu leur dis qu'est ce qui
se passe qu'est ce que j'ai fait non
mais en fait ils m'ont posé quelques
questions qui m'ont dit qu'ils m'ont un
peu interpellé parce qu'il m'ont dit
monsieur vous êtes gay moi j'ai dit oui
sans vraiment comme si j'étais à new
york fin j'habite à new york si le
tanneur est en fait ils m'ont et m'ont
dit vous savez que cette substance était
légale en turquie jusqu'à demi jusqu'à
juillet 2016 il m'a souri il m'a fait un
grand sourire comme si je ne sais pas je
je pense que je vais pas dire que le gbl
était une excuse pour me pour m'arrêter
parce qu'ils savaient que cette drogue
est utilisé beaucoup dans le milieu
d'accord gay et donc c'était vous vous
êtes dit il m'attendait au tournant donc
bah je suis pas devant vous avez répondu
aux savants et la voilà et là bah oui
non si elle l'a dit bienvenue bienvenu
dans ta nouvelle maison quand il a
ouvert la porte de la prison ah ouais
donc là tu te retrouves en prison ont
tué qui au début tu te dis quoi tu dis
que cette affaire avait été vite réglé
tu te dis ça c'est pas possible ça va
exactement donc la tête arrivent en
prison en turquie donc là tu es tu
arrivé ou déjà c'est quoi la première
mal tpc dans la banlieue d'istanbul
d'accord c'était une prison pour
étrangers d'accord mais les cellules
sont de 50 à 60 personnes que avec des
étrangers donc la carrer dans une
cellule de 50 à 60 personnes d'accord il
a dû faire ma première nuit en garde à
vue je suis arrivé dans une cellule
entre 50 et 60 personnes et donc
ben c'est un peu un choc un choc enfin
indescriptible a bien sûr ce que je
passe de ça de ma vie à
la perche couvert soumettre sous mes
pieds donc là et là la juste fabien
dû renter dans cette prison tu dis quoi
tu dis tu dis je peux appeler personne
je me retrouve là que tu comprend ce qui
se passe non pas du tout encore non je
me dis que c'est un film je fais un
cauchemar je vais je vais me réveiller
je me disais c'est bien passé juste pas
possible c'est alors pas non plus tard
en 2018 puisque tu vas rester déjà un
nom tu reste combien de temps dans cette
prison je suis resté de septembre 2010
est à
janvier 2001
avec dans une cellule de 2 50 à 60
personnes oui il y avait beaucoup de
failles et toutous crimes confondus donc
les cellules des cellules turc en tout
cas mal tp était tous crimes confondus
donc avait de toute façon je vais pas
vous faire là tout est calé il y avait
des terroristes des violeurs d'enfants
des dealers de drogue des voleurs des
femmes y avait de tout donc toi tu te
retrouves là bas oui
c'est vrai que quand on se retrouve là
mais juste moi la question je me pose tu
te dis mais j'essaie de parler à
quelqu'un tu essaie d'avoir un ce qui te
laisse passer un coup de fil ou rien du
tout comme quand ça se passe
avant ma garde à vue mais ils m'ont
laissé passer une minute c'est quand j
une mine c'est 60 secondes d'accord de
de téléphone à mon père d'accord qui est
vraiment expliquer quoi ton père tu as
dit je suis revenu a mal jugé normal je
me fais mettre en prison mon père a
explosé en larmes et puis le policier a
ensuite coupé la ligne donc ensuite mon
frère qui est ici on note d'ailleurs que
je dois remercier parce que c'est lui
tout démarré et
et donc
je suis un peu perdue dans les pensées
losc pas là c'est pas grave fabien on
s'inquiète pas en haletant
on est bien avec toi on a le temps on
t'écoute donc
mon père a appelé le frère mon père
appelé mon frère quand je suis arrivé à
malte et p c'est
un choc des cultures parce que
européens américains et pas exactement
la même culture que que en turquie mais
aussi ses c'est s'adapter à 50 ou 60
personnalités complètement différente
que qui était tellement à l'ouest de
monde monde mon univers donc ça c'était
un peu ça c'était très très très dur
alors là très vite en prison tu es
conditions des tensions vont se dégrader
et devenir terrible puisque dans une
première prison tu vas être victime de
tentative de meurtre
l'agression physique on va dire ce qui
s'est passé on m'a envoyé un de de l'eau
bouillante sur le visage sur le corps
ça ans en raison actifs de quoi bein je
je je
on m'a dit il m'a dit qu'on m'a dit de 2
que c'était pour ma religion il a été
aussi condamné pour la us six mois et
plus une à une une amende assez
importante il a été condamné par la cour
enfin le tribunal heures en prison
mais bon comme il avait 125 ans à purger
pour lui c'était pas grand chose c'était
c'était un bonus on va dire ça c'est ça
qui a été visible donc parce que tu
étais tu dis aussi été visée parce que
tu es juif et homosexuel aussi dans là
bas je pense dans la foulée ça c'est un
pas dû jouer en ma faveur
les conditions c'était quoi les
conditions de détention
c'était
très dur mais je sais pas je ne sais pas
comment comment vous expliquer parce que
j'ai des zips pas d'autre chose at un
jeu pourrait le comparer avec la france
mais ça a tellement rien à voir que que
quand arrivé en prison en france tu t'es
dit sais
c'est quoi ça c'est complètement
différent ça n'avait ça n'avait rien à
voir avec la turquie déjà les les les
surveillants turquie ont le droit de
vous vous tapez d'accord alors qu'en
france il n'y a pas de ça et c'est un
système à la militaire donc huit heures
c'est l'heure 8h01 ces pudeurs si vous
aviez vous arriver si vous arrivez en
retard pour l'appel de huit heures ben
on les surveille on vous tape alors
qu'en france les appels c'est entre
entre 7 heures et 7 heures 20 ce qui est
assez relax on va dire mais c'est ça
reste quand même la prison mais disons
on n'a pas peur de se faire moi j'avais
plus peur en france de me faire taper
par les surveillants c'était quoi le
moment le plus dur
quand le juge en prison ou prison
d'abord cette agression déjà à cette
agression c'est l'agression et je vois
encore les yeux de mon agresseur l'a la
haine alors que le titre je le
connaissais je connais ni son nom je
l'avais il est hélas non dans la cellule
pendant deux jours avant de l'agresser
il connaissait rien sur moi je ne
connaissais rien sur lui j'avais même
pas un organe ceux ci ne s'était même
pas croisés
et donc
donc la gestion reste un moment assez
difficile à me remémorer et
le moment où le juge m'a donné vingt ans
vingt ans de prison 20 ans qui ont été
ramenés à 16 ans et huit mois pour pour
bon comportement à l'audience une
audience qui a duré quand même 15
minutes enfin en étant en 15 minutes en
étant généreux alors tu vas être ensuite
déplacé tués détenus à 800 km au
nord-est d'istanbul dans une prison
difficile d'accès où tu partage sa
cellule avec huit autres co détenus l'un
aux début d'accord oui ça se passe mieux
pour toi là-bas oui mais c'est
je suis pas resté très longtemps cette
cellule il nous aimons l'idée ils ont
éclaté la cellule très rapidement quand
est-ce qu'on était tous étrangers est en
fait il voulait intégrer giresun était
une prison à 90% turc donc il voulait
soit que enfin les autorités
pénitentiaires voulait soit que nous
apprenions aux turcs qui étaient pas
vraiment possible pour pour d'autres
raisons soit que nous enseignons
l'anglais ou le français ou l'espagnol
aux eaux turques qui était pas possible
donc et en fait on disait et éclater la
cellule de luis pedro et des neuf dans
la cellule où huit plus noir 9 et ils
ont ils nous ont mis dans une cellule
qui était à majoritairement turc et là
on a été
c'était été c'était très dur parce que
les montagnes et sont pas du tout les
mêmes et parce que là la télévision
n'était qu'en turc toute façon y avait
pas une seule chaîne intéressant
internationale donc pour nous pour les
étrangers en été de 4,5 dans la dans la
cellule étrangère c'était encore plus
dur tu as vécu des moments encore
difficile à des agressions des danseurs
physiques et morales physiques non non
après celle ci mais je pense que je m'en
rappelle j'ai encore le que le corps
pour me le rappeler est
mais par contre j'ai des agressions
mentale oui de quel type
parce qu'on m'a dit on va essayer aussi
de convertir
peut pas la prison offre en turquie la
possibilité de se convertir d'accord
elle vous verse 400 lira donc ça fait
pour le 40 euros si vous vous
convertissez c'est pas on vous forcent
d'accord c'est encourager si vous voulez
le faire cesser ces possibles il ya des
codétenus à moi qu'ils l'ont fait
d'accord et si tu le fais pas ça va
c'est s'est passé pas mal non nikaïa il
n'y a pas d'accord qu'on très bien où
vous le propose si vous aussi vous le
faites il vous ils vous font un acte ii
un certificat de conversion et et voilà
mais ya pas deux il n'y a pas de vous
forcer à faire ça comment tu as fait
pour tenir quand tu dis je vais passé
vingt ans en prison en turquie je me le
suis on les dit jamais dit je vais
passer je me dis je me suis dit
même après les 20 ans de sursaut monde
sous ma fiche pénale ou les 16 ans 8
mois sur ma fiche pénale je me suis j'ai
pas un moment dit je vais rester 20 ans
ici je me disais c'est pas possible le
cauchemar il va s'arrêter il va
s'arrêter mais là ça faisait quand même
4 on oui enfin
juste les avocats en turquie n'ont rien
réussi à faire mais je savais que dans
le
dans le background dans le monde y sera
en français en coulisses est jolie qu'on
lui a menti quand même ah oui c'est vrai
ouais quand vous lui avez fait à dion
pour son frère on a forcé son frère à
lui mentir on lui doit les espoirs voilà
donc lui d'ici un an ont reculé à chaque
fois mais ont donné une date butoir sur
soi une réouverture du dossier soit un
transfèrement systématiquement à trois
quatre mois maximum et après on était
obligé lui tient compte et une sur toi à
chaque fois mais on s'est dit si et si
on lui ment pas il tiendra pas honnête
j'avais crevé lit j'avais toujours cru
qu'ils avaient toujours cru qu'à relever
ouais vraiment oui oui c'est pas dire
moment c'est ça ça va pas y arriver bah
le moment on a décidé de médiatiser je
me suis dit c'est plus possible en fait
parce que on avait des interlocuteurs au
ministère des affaires étrangères c'est
des gens qui ont plusieurs dossiers à
gérer et à quand j'ai compris que je
n'avais pas réalisé que c'était un cas
particulier et qu'en fait il n'y avait
pas transfert de la turquie vers la
france j'ai posé la question à
l'ambassadeur de france en turquie j'ai
dit donnez moi le nom d'un français qui
a été transféré ces dix dernières années
silence au téléphone ce jour là j'ai
compris que sans les médias on n'y
arriverait pas
parce qu'on est resté quand même
silencieux pendant longtemps bien sûr
moi c'est ça c'est ça parce qu'on a fait
confiance à la diplomatie parce qu'on
nous a dit si vous médiatisé ça va être
très difficile pour nous de faire notre
travail je suivais il peut devenir une
mode et les chants jeux ils peuvent se
braquer les autorités là bas donc
surtout il faut absolument pas que je
sais je vais vous raconter aussi mal
d'anecdotes là dessus parce que j'ai
voulu intervenir un moment et vous
raconter ce qu'on m'a dit c'est vrai que
ces essais c'est compliqué il faut être
c'est vraiment extrêmement compliqué
c'est vrai qu'on rentre dans une bande
et dans des rouages où il faut être
extrêmement prudent parce que même quand
on veut faire le bien parfois ça peut
être au contraire ça peut ça peut amener
des mauvaises décisions justement voilà
donc il fallait être extrêmement prudent
c'est ce que vous avez fait je sais
qu'il ya des souvenirs très dur
pour ne voulait pas parler comme
vous avez u11 par un codétenu qui a été
tuée je crois je prouve avec ce jeu
préféré éviter deux oui ça c'est un truc
de remblaiement de taille ce que vous en
avez parlé dans votre lettre si vous
avez écrit de nombreuses lettres
esseyric dans ces lettres on ressentait
l'horreur vraiment que
tout ce que vous viviez david et
personne ne peut imaginer les horreurs
auxquelles j'ai assisté ce n'est juste
pas concevable ici ce sont tous des
récidivistes ils ont l'habitude des
prisons mais moi non je ne sais même pas
me défendre en fait je crois que tout
est étudié pour faire souffrir au
maximum ici c'est une prison
psychologique comme ils le disent
toutes ses horreurs
ouais
un jour dans une des lettres tu reviens
sur donc cet épisode terrifiant horrible
j'aurais dû commencer cette lettre il ya
une semaine mais ma tête parfois c'est
un complètement face aux horreurs
auxquelles je fais face quotidiennement
la dernière en date est un type qui
s'est fait trancher la gorge par un
groupe de quatre syriens je dormais
quand c'est arrivé mais les cris des
détenus m'ont réveillé la vue du sang
partout était effrayante pire que dans
un film d'horreur
j'ai appris par la suite que le détenu
et qui est décédé avait fait des avances
à l'un des six rien qu au nom d'allah il
devait le payer de sa vie tu fais de son
homosexualité bien entendu je suis
depuis le début
de retour dans le placard et personne ne
sait que je suis folle
pour la protection jeu je devais du j'ai
dû faire cette semaine ce bouclier ce
samedi vanté cette personne que je
n'étais pas pour pouvoir survivre mais
ça a été dur cette agression pour en
revenir à l'agression
physique dont j'ai été vous avez cru
mourir à ce moment là vous êtes diva
arrive à me tuer non parce que c'était
avec de l'eau bouillante ont même heure
avec biblique double ans mais j'ai quand
même
on m'a les codétenus dont il était avec
nous pendant deux jours deux jours avant
avant le avant de mon agression est en
fait il ya des codétenus qui m'ont dit
ce mec il veut changer toutes les règles
du delà de la cellule il veut que tout
le monde prie cinq fois par jour
le monde mon agresseur en jeu
il veut compris de cinq fois par jour il
veut changer toutes les règles de la
cellule et puis bon moi je ceux qui
veulent prix e-prix moi moi je n'étais
pas de confession musulmane mais je
n'étais rien officiellement je n'allais
pas commencer à prier cinq fois par jour
qui m'a pas il m'a pas forcée à le faire
mais peut-être peu je sais pas mais en
tout cas ça lui a plu et m'a marc
agressé alors mon nom de famille est
aussi assez typique de ma religion et
donc il y avait des codétenus qui ont
peut-être commencé le téléphone arabe
met en prison ces puissances disent donc
peut-être c'était pas arrivé assez à ses
oreilles et peut-être que y'en a un qui
m'a dit de toute façon que lost his te
tuer je vais directement au paradis donc
et c'est pas moi qui me suis dit je suis
juif je ne suis pas du tout comme ça
vous avez quand même des personnes des
rencontres ou voilà qui qui qui ont
changé aussi
votre façon de penser ou avec des des
rencontres vraiment vous étiez des amis
je sais pas là bas parmi les codétenus
ont des amis non parce que j'étais pas
là pour faire des amis non mais c'est
pas là pour faire des ennemis non plus
mais à un moment il ya des cultes a des
liens qui se créent oui oui oui il ya eu
quelques ya eu quelques beaux moments où
dur moment je pense y ait un lien des
québécois de rien qui m'a enseigné
l'espagnol et à qui j'enseigne le
français
qui a perdu son frère
pendant que
pendant son acoustique incarcération et
moi je pensais à mon frère et je me
faisais mais si je perdais mon frère
pendant l'incarcération mais ça serait
là ça serait vraiment vraiment la fin
donc ça c'était un moment du enfin dur
pour lui mais aussi
vu que j'avais un peu lié d'amitié avec
lui on avait partagé quelques quelques
quelques quelques rires même si c'était
des rires forcés pour la plupart du
temps
ça m'a fait de la peine pour lui et je
me disais mais voilà ça pourrait être si
cette arrivée à toi mais alors là ça
serait la fin de la fin c'était quoi les
veaux journée en prison en turquie
au début au milieu ou la fin de mon
incarcération parce que ça fait 4 enfin
80 ça répond et le le le voilà la
journée type au début c'est quoi vous
je gardais de somnifères pour essayer de
dormir
tous voulaient en fait vous lui
demandiez si indifférent alors il y
avait alors contourné avec les étrangers
il y avait quelques étrangers qui vivent
est arrivé beaucoup de syriens ou
irakiens qui vivait en turquie depuis
longtemps donc qui connaissait le turc
entend qu'ils écrivaient les pétitions
enfin l'effet fallait faire des
pétitions pour tous aux autorités
pénitentiaires pour réclamer un
traitement médicamenteux ou ou d une
visite pour aller voir le directeur ou
pour
pour un parloir ou point de
droit au téléphone enfin ou d'affaires
les dix minutes de téléphone
hebdomadaire que qu'on a qu'on avait et
donc je sais plus où j'étais on était
sur les somnifères les somnifères donc
oui je prenais des doses des doses de 2e
pas le de somnifères pour pour m'abrutir
quoi pour eux pour me
mener stasi le cerveau me dit c'est pas
possible c'est un moment ou un autre ça
va s'arrêter ça veut pas ça peut pas
continuer comme ça en entendant bien
longtemps et donc il y avait c'est donc
c'est somnifères que je prenais et puis
à part après mon agression il y avait un
détenu un des co détenus qui m'a dit
fabien garde toujours un couteau sous
son oreiller parce qu'on sait jamais été
en prison et donc après mon agression
j'ai gardé et j'avais toujours un
couteau sous mon oreiller et si vous
voulez quand vous pas moi je bouge
beaucoup pendant la nuit quand vous
mettez votre main sous un oreiller et
vous vous réalisez qu'il ya un couteau
enfin vous toutes les nuits ça
recommence mais je me suis dit mais
c'est juste pas possible c'est c'est ma
vie est devenue un enfer mais pire qu'un
enfer pire qu'un film un mauvais film de
2,2 de policiers ou de là un film
d'horreur vous avez pensé à l'utiliser
un jour n'y avait jamais eu un moment où
et melvieu oui mais j'aurais même pas su
comment l'utiliser en fait j'ai pensé il
ya eu des moments où on a dit ça va
alors je me barricader alors après avoir
passé un certain temps en prison je me
barricader dans ces délits se
superposent et je me barricader avec des
couvertures en fait pour pour eux savoir
qu'ils rentraient dans la cellule je
faisais des micro trous dans la dans la
couverture parce que quand vous êtes
dans l'intérieur du lit vous voyez vous
vous avez un angle de vision que la
personne n'a pas quand elle vient dans
la dans la pièce si vous voulez d'accord
donc et moi j'ai un sucre elle et je
suis très light sleepers je les jugeais
je suis un dormeur léger
et
est donc
une mouche qui vole me réveille d'accord
donc quand j'entendais le moindre doute
pas je me réveillais je regardais city
venait dans la danse dans la chambre en
fait et donc je prenais mon couteau si
je me faisait agresser je pourrais
peut-être menacer la personne ne
l'aurait pas su comment comment utiliser
un couteau je sais pas je sais pas te
faire mal de mal à un animal imaginez
une personne un humain alors ensuite
grâce à la mobilisation à la
médiatisation la france a obtenu tout
rapatriement le 17 août comment tu la
prends alors c'est mon avocate
avec un anonyme une de mes avocate avec
un anonyme qui qui m'apprennent avec mon
frère
xavier au téléphone et je me souviens
fait toujours pas ce qu'elle m'a dit
elle a dit allez on lui dit et là c'est
que l'on puisse commencer à fondre en
larmes au téléphone presse que je me
suis dit ça ça pour cette fenêtre pour
une fois c'est une vraie une vraie
nouvelle ça c'est du pur si elles me
disent ah si il me dit ça ça veut dire
ça m'a vraiment se passer parce que les
avocats en turquie m'ont dit les
dizaines de fois toi tu sort demain et
puis on est allés d'audience en veut
dire ans a duré à peine en appel et de
deux courts en cours et c'est toujours
été non non non non non non non jusqu'à
ce que ce ce jour où ou m montano m'a
dit au téléphone
chut c'est ça a été accepté par la
france et par la turquie et ton
transfert était imminent et lauriane on
anonymes qui m'a dit profil bien de ton
dernier week-end en turquie dont ça m'a
fait rire parce que mais j'y croyais
j'ai même quand ils m'ont dit j'ai pas
krugier pas cru jusqu'à ce que la porte
de l'avion se referment et qu on décode
aucune information avant qu'il ya sur le
sol français parce qu'on savait pas ce
qui pouvait se passer c'était un titre
historique d'autant plus que trois
semaines avant il ya le directeur de la
prison qui est venu le voir qui lui a
dit ça y est tu vas être transféré cette
nuit prêts partez à faire alors il a
tout préparé il a attendu toute la nuit
le lendemain ils lui ont dit non mais
finalement ce sera peut-être demain
après demain ou après après demain donc
il attend il attend et finalement le
jeudi on l'a au téléphone et il nous dit
il nous raconte ce qui s'est passé il
nous dit donc c'est bon demain je vais
être transférés on lui dit non non et là
il sait ça arrive d'avoir des nouvelles
souvent son frère l'avait au téléphone
tous les jeudis d'accord dix minutes
d'accord ok dix militaires est maman de
deux bambins de 2 juillet ponce enrile
leaf et d'angoissant même temps parce
que j'attends des nouvelles assez avoir
quelqu'un à voir à cause du cobp il y
avait plus du tout de visite en turquie
en plus cités cd tellement loin il
devait prendre trois avions pour venir
me voir j'ai dit c'est pas la peine ils
ont repris les visites mais je vais
quand même dit j'ai interdit de venir me
voir je les mange eux les menti parce
que je voulais pas venez me voir pour 40
minutes faire faire huit heures de
trajet pour 40 minutes ça valait pas le
coup alors au début ils venaient boire
toutes les semaines au début quand
j'étais en gp toutes les semaines il
était là imaginer faire par istanbul
istanbul paris juste pour 45 minutes de
visite ça c'est un frère bah oui ça
c'est un frère que comme je souhaite
aller dans les coulisses 1 ce soir
j'aurais aimé qu'il vienne mais il veut
pas à ben bon lembras quand même
formidable alors oui il ya je crois que
nicolas sarkozy a essayé de vous aider
c'est ça oui il a reçu mon frère
pour ça j'en suis très très très
reconnaissant parce que ça pour moi ça a
été déjà un message d'espoir me dis
alors voilà ok côté qu' turquie me bloch
qui veulent pas il veut pas que je sorte
ils sont têtus comme on va pas dire mais
comme on dit têtu comme une tête de turc
c'est sain c'est non mais bon on peut
dit je sais pas si
on peut
aimer côté français je me sui bat déjà
qui est un homme politique qui croit en
moi ça m'a redonné un peu d'espoir alors
je sais que de toute façon
si on dit
si les turcs n'avaient pas voulu le
faire que les français leur dise vous
devez faire ça je l'aurais pas fait
voilà qu'est ce qui a fait changer les
choses carole la médiatisation c'est ça
qui a fait ça a été le déclic bah oui
moi si vous voulez quand je l'appelle au
ministère des affaires étrangères les
hôtes au début on s'adresse à moi
parfois on se trompe de dossiers
d'accord donc on a des conversations et
tout d'un coup je me dis mais attendez
vous parlez de quel dossier là d'accord
et puis après la médiatisation tout d'un
coup on sait de qui on parle et on est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus écouter ce
qui a aussi beaucoup changé les choses
c'est le dialogue qu'on a pu avoir avec
l'ambassadeur de turquie qui a été de
nous voir ici d'ailleurs oui
réalité avoue été top non il a été au
point le bruit ouais oui parce que ça a
été un interlocuteur qui s'est investie
sur le dossier alors après dans son rôle
il a jamais
outre passé c'est que c'est sûr mais
simplement d'une très grande
disponibilité voilà est très à l'écouté
j'ai trouvé que
[Musique]
en
tout cas on pouvait échanger directement
et c'était important savait pas toujours
été le cas côté français et puis après
il ya eu cette rencontre qui a été
annoncé c'est françois zimeray donc
l'autre avocat de fabien azoulay qui a
appris que ils allaient se rencontrer le
lundi donc ça on l'a su le vendredi
qu'ils allaient se rencontrer leonardo
gamme emmanuel macron et président r de
nanas et se rencontrer et vous avez
publicis était pas donc j'avais pu
glisser un mot au président macron qui
en a parlé c'est me mettre des mre qui
sont les occuper mon confrère françois
zimeray on a rédigé les courriers et
puis ensuite voilà il faut qu'il soit
transmis au bon moment à la bonne
personne
on peut imaginer qu'il ya aussi d'autres
gens qui ont été touchés par la sphère
de fabien qui ont pu aussi poussé à ce
que ça se fasse parce que c'est pas
évident dans une rencontre comme ça dans
le contexte des relations franco turques
à ce moment là que le cas de fabien
azoulay soit évoqué parce que si vous
voulez quand on regarde le dossier comme
ça on peut on peut se dire et c'est ce
que beaucoup sont dit au départ oh bah
finalement c'est comme tous les autres
dealers il raconte que il n'a rien à
voir avec l'histoire et puis hop on
passe à autre chose il faut regarder les
faits il faut il faut il faut croire en
lui pour qu'on se rendre compte que
c'est rien de tout ça mais sauf que si
vous ouvrez pas le dossier que vous
lisez pas va vous le mettez sur la pile
avec les autres et puis on attend et
puis c'est pas grave y'a quelqu'un qui
n'a pas encore plus de voir mais qui
voulait absolument d'adresser un message
ce soir c'est un grand ami à toi c'est
david qui a énormément bougé aussi
regardent enfin bien que tu sais j'ai
pas pu être avec vous ce soir je suis à
des milliers de kilomètres mais j'aurais
tellement voulu partager ce moment pour
te dire à quel point je t'aime et tu
nous as manqué mais je profitais de ta
présence avec cyril hanouna pour saluer
son incroyable investissement personnel
pour ton histoire tout le monde
reconnaît ses efforts à l'antenne le
dialogue diplomatique qu'il a réussi à
instaurer mais en coulisse cyril a été
un homme d'honneur il a pris de tes
nouvelles tout l'été il a été un relais
incroyable sur les réseaux sociaux et
jamais pour quelques bénéfices que ce
soit ils étaient prêts à venir pour
chercher avec moi à istanbul cet été le
dit à la fois en rigolant et
sérieusement donc merci infiniment cyril
qui sauve un homme sauve l'humanité et
tu a clairement contribué à sa liberté
enfin librement fabien geste de deuxième
vingt les bras
[Applaudissements]
non moi je voulais juste aller istanbul
pour les vacances
d'été voilà non mais je suis tellement
heureux pour toi vraiment je suis très
ému je sois là ce soir est-ce que tu as
un dernier mois nous dire ça est-ce que
tu un dernier mois nous dire ce soir
takeshi un grand merci à toi parce que
c'est cesser ça a été je pense le
déclencheur de tout
bon mon frère car mon avocate une
avocate qui a essaimé avocat
gilles tiens oui à l'école salaires est
très très réglo et elle est enfin chaque
à blanc
et donc il ya eu il ya eu
il ya à partir du moment où toi tu as
mis les des ambassadeurs en face à face
mais tous et tout s'est enchaîné tout
s'est enchaîné rien moi j'ai rien su de
tout ça en turquie parce que tu es les
turcs il parle pas il papa de tpm paix à
la télé dessus alors je sais que j'ai un
petit succès la
folie qui aurait que je remercie aussi
l'ambassadeur idrac est venu sur le
plateau et je pense que ça c'est ça qui
a joué aussi un et qui peut remercier
olivier david qui ont été assez grave
c'est grâce à deux c'est grâce à ton
frère à carole et à david pasquet à toi
n'aurait jamais su la faire nommer
vraiment c'est eux qui ont fait que on a
pu en parler dans cette émission dont tu
peux tu peux vraiment les remercier on
est heureux pour toi on espère
maintenant que tu vas pouvoir
vivre ta vie normalement pouvoir
commencer quelque chose et là tout à
reconstruire c'est ça ouais voilà tu
arrives à temps plein tu arrives à mes
médicaments avec avec continue instant
tard un traitement assez assez carabine
aimé mais j' espère à terme pouvoir me
sevrer de tout ça dans le chimique c'est
pas dur c'est pas du temps c'est pas de
la mélatonine pour l'instant tu as tu
reprends une vie normale mais tu es
toujours ça fait deux jours que je suis
là que j'ai atterri ce que je je je là
j'avais même pas à croire que je suis
serein sur un plateau télé en train de
parler de mon histoire 25-20 castaldi et
adultes